[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un flat aujourd'hui on
va se tester un smartphone
l'articulation des fois ça fait m c'est
dur on va tester un smartphone c'est un
smartphone de samsung
en ce moment je vois pas mal de samsung
parce que l actu qui est vraiment forte
avec la galaxie aux âges pour la tester
l'autre jour avec l'athabasca qu'on a
également testé le jour et si on veut
trouver le smartphone qu'on va tester
aujourd'hui il faut surmonter tout ça
passait derrière même pas il est pas là
ah non il est là il est caché là il y en
a tellement je le vois plus on va tester
aujourd'hui le samsung galaxy à 6 plus
j'ai testé il ya pas très longtemps le
samsung galaxy à 6 maintenant place aux
grands modèles pour voir si vaut le coup
oui ou non
alors qu'elle est à celles qui étaient
présentes et l'autre jour maintenant on
va rester celui là ça peut être pas mal
bon la boîte elle est assez minimaliste
mais plutôt efficace ça faisait un petit
moment que j'ai envie de le voir alors
je vous ai dit j'ai testé l'autre mais
le grand modèle à mon avis il a des
avantages non négligeables et souvent
comme ça voilà samsung galaxy à 6 +
écran de 6 pouces 2160 par 1080 pixels
la densité de pixels cdu 411 ppp je
trouve que ce grand modèle est plutôt
cool il se prend bien dans la main il
est pas trop trop large pour le coup il
est assez facile à maîtriser cette
manière là on n'a rien notre double
module photo 16 mégapixels + 5
mégapixels qui vous servira pour la
profondeur de champ ont pour les faits
bloqué à l'avant vous avez une grande
caméra de 24 mégapixels vous pouvez
filmer au maximum en 1080p 1920 par 1080
pixels
ici pas de quatre cas mais
fondamentalement ça fera la faire pour
les photos ce sera du 4608 par 3456 16
mégapixels format 4/3 vous aussi le
passé en 16/9 comme vous souhaitez à
l'avant vous pouvez filmer en 24
mégapixels et faire des vidéos en full
hd bien évidemment il ya une prise en
charge du hdr pas mal de petites options
minuteur choses comme ça ça marche bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'écran est vraiment appréciable pour
regarder vos vidéos écran de 6 pouces ça
pour le coup c'est vraiment bien chez
samsung pas d'encoches donc on n'a
absolument rien ici vous êtes quelque
chose d'assez équilibré entre le bord
droit et le bord gauche et en plus ce
qui est vraiment bien ces leçons par
l'or se situe ici on a l'habitude a
d'abord à des haut parleurs mono sur le
côté voyez ici on a absolument aucun
alors bien évidemment si on a pas on
n'utilise pas le haut parleur ici on a
un haut parleur qui est logé ici et ça
pour le coup c'est assez original
ce qui fait que lorsque vous le tenez
comme ça vous allez absolument pas
bouché les haut parleurs
ici non plus vous pouvez lire et vous
avez le son qui vient du dessus et ça
pour le coup c'est super cool chez
samsung on a gardé la prise jack
c'est nickel il ya du son il ya un
spectre qui est vraiment très bien les
graves sont cool c'est pas criard ça
marche plutôt bien
donc là dessus aussi très bon point
samsung le dos et cool
l'écran est cool maintenant en termes de
performances c'est loin d'être une bête
de compet avec un score de 69 1463 sûr
en tout il est largement en dessous des
50 premiers du classement
néanmoins son utilisation standard
classique pour utiliser pour vos jeux
pour pouvoir naviguer sur internet
relever d email allez sur instagram
faire tout genre de choses il marchera
plutôt pas mal à noter que dessus vous
avez instinct dragonne 450 cadencé
maximum jusqu'à 1,8 gr 3 giga de ram 32
gigas de stockage il tourne sous android
8 oreo avec la surcouche de samsung
expérience lui alors en termes
d'utilisation
je vous le dis j'ai absolument rien à
lui reprocher sur utilisation standard
dès qu'on va chercher un regain de
puissance
très clairement c'est pas là dessus
qu'il faut aller néanmoins pour les
trois quarts des choses qu'on va faire
avec
il ira parfaitement bien bon on va
cesser ce smartphone dans différentes
conditions de luminosité
là on laisse au double module arrière 16
mégapixels + 5 mégapixels c'est
forcément la 16 mégapixels qui fit l'a5
servira pour le mode portrait on va donc
filmé ici en conditions de bonne
luminosité sur la caméra arrière mais
également sur la caméra avant on va
mettre à regarder en faible luminosité
sans les caméras rire sur les caméras
avant on va faire quelques photos et
puis on va débriefer tout ça je filme
caméra
la main pour voir un petit peu la
stabilisation voire sous 17 appareils
bon vous savez qu'avec moi dès que c'est
pas stabilisée tout de suite ça pardonne
pas et maintenant on va regarder sur la
caméra à l'avant il ya de la lumière
donc forcément ça marche bien capteurs
24 mégapixels par contre 24 mégapixels
mais l'objectif doit pas avoir une
ouverture dingue j'ai déjà testé tout à
leur faible luminosité je veux couper la
lumière vous allez voir ça va ramener
beaucoup de bruit là je mets un peu de
côté mais un peu de côté voilà là tout
de suite ça me ramène du bruit regarder
sur mon et là il ya beaucoup de bruit il
ya du bruit là tandis que l'arrière qui
est beaucoup plus éclairée une en soufre
absolument pas et lorsque je reviens
tout de suite ici ça marche forcément de
suite beaucoup mieux lâche toujours sans
la caméra avant par contre à l'extérieur
si forcément il ya beaucoup plus de
lumière
là ça va très très bien mise à pearl
espèce d'énorme goûtons par la tête même
sur ce profil là absolument pas de bruit
la qualité pas trop mal d'ailleurs dites
moi ce que vous en pensez vous en
commentaire ce qu'on va en regardant les
photos et vidéos
c'est que on n'est pas sur le meilleur
appareil photo de samsung ça vous en
douterez il ya du reste neuf plus est
d'une haute 9 ans prod qui ont des
résultats qui sont vraiment doc
néanmoins dans cette gamme de prix je
dirais sur l'entrée de gamme du milieu
de gamme
c'est un petit peu comme ça il fait
plutôt bien à faire alors il marchera
bien lorsque vous nourrissez avec
beaucoup de lumière dès lors qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de lumière ça marchera
moins bien que ce soit pour la photo et
pour la vidéo
mais une fois de plus on lit sur un
smartphone à moins de 300 euros
on attend lui demander la lune point de
vue autonomie vous avez batterie de
trois mille cinq cents millions terreur
qui venait de le garder en charge il
journée complète alors ça dépend
toujours toujours toujours votre
utilisation
si vous êtes très gourmand très gourmand
que vous allez beaucoup dessus
toujours sur internet a regardé beaucoup
de vidéos écouter beaucoup de musique
faire beaucoup de photos beaucoup d'un
stade de stats et compagnie forcément
l'autonomie et va fondre comme neige au
soleil
et là il va falloir recharger un peu
plus tôt que prévu néanmoins son
utilisation standard vous gardez une
journée complète sans aucun problème et
ça c'est très bien un hôtel dessus vous
avez du bluetooth 7.2 et de la recharge
en micro usb
ici pas d'usb type celle ci c'est un
smartphone que je trouve pas mal dans la
gamme de samsung
néanmoins avec l'arrivée du galaxy à
cette ya pas longtemps à mon avis
risque rapidement d'être un petit peu
déclassé on va que samsung élargit
complètement son nombre de modèles pour
faire face à la concurrence chinoise qui
est de plus en plus pressante à 6 à 6
plus à 7 à 8
rien dans la gamme à il ya eu pas mal de
nouveautés cette année dans la gabegie
également est alors ne parlons pas du
haut de gamme avec le s9 heslov plus est
avec le galaxy note 9
samsung se doit d'être présente sur tous
les segments pour tous types de clients
pour tous types de consommateurs ce
galaxy à 6 plus est très bien il n'a pas
forcément un petit plus par rapport au
galaxy à 6 notamment au niveau de la
caméra
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai bien lire
dans la description je ne peux que vous
recommander ce produit j'aime beaucoup
les produits de samsung
je trouve très bien après j'ai un seul
doute là dessus non pas du tout sur la
performance sur la qualité de ce produit
sur l'écran amoled qui est vraiment très
bien et toujours une belle réussite et
samsung mais c'est par rapport à la
concurrence chinoise pour des produits
moins 300 euros - que de trouver plus
performants ailleurs et c'est un petit
peu ça qui pourrait lui faire mal dites
moi vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez ce sont nos plats
je suis là comment vous trouvez le
samsung galaxy s qui plus est ce que
vous avez déjà le samsung galaxy sii
c'est ce que vous avez un autre modèle
de la gamme art ou un autre modèle de
chez samsung
dites moi comment vous trouvez et par
rapport à son prix il est à moins de 300
euros
quand vous dire des bêtises par rapport
aux différents magasins où vous pouvez
le trouver il sera pas toujours au même
prix néanmoins dans cette gamme de
tarifs
il ya une concurrence qui est vraiment
féroce dites moi donc ce que vous en
pensez parce qu'à moins de 300 euros on
se retrouve entre le haut de gamme de
l'entrée de gamme et l'entrée de gamme
du moyen de gamme
voilà on est un petit peu entre les deux
en attendant celui-là ton qui fait
franchement les jeunes dites moi ce que
vous en pensez vous un commentaire on en
parle on reste connectés des produits de
samsung va en tester plein la g la
galaxie watch au poignet j'en ai parlé
il ya quelques temps la table s 4
également on va tester très bientôt le
samsung galaxy s est donc vous invite à
faire une seule chose c'est à vous
abonner et à rester connectés
[Musique]